now I'm not a web dev but I do need to
make websites sometimes and so because
of that I feel like I'm on an endless
quest to find the easiest best
frictionless way to just get a website
up and running that just works is
lightweight and easy to set up lets me
focus on the content that I want to
write and the information I want to
display did I mention easy and simple
and I think I found it I think I found
my new favorite way to make websites
which is what brings us to this video
here this is what feels like just an
annual view of my favorite way to make a
website and I guess this is the 2023
Edition so yes Hazel my game engine now
has a brand new website which you can
see over here this is what it looks like
of course it also looks nice on mobile
and this is what the Hazel website used
to look like this was the Hazel website
up until now and now we have switched to
something that I think is a lot nicer a
lot more simple it's got a really easy
way for us to write like some articles
just using markdown which is fantastic
fantastic and more importantly it solves
some of the serious issues that we had
with this site and with the approach
that I took to building this so in this
video I'm going to talk about how I made
the old site and why that wasn't good
enough I'm also obviously going to talk
about how I made the new site and what
technology I used for that and then in
the second half of this video I'm going
to show you how you can set up a website
like this from scratch I'll show you the
whole process from scratch that you can
use to get up and running with basically
the same setup that we're using here for
this new Hazel engine website okay so
first and foremost this old Hazel engine
website how was this made well to give a
little bit of History I knew that what I
basically wanted was just a static
website like I don't need people to be
able to log in I don't need various
authors writing content using a web
interface like WordPress would provide
you know I didn't want any of that I
didn't want like this huge PHP backend I
just wanted HTML I honestly just wanted
to keep this as simple as possible and
so what I did is I bought this this is
not that expensive it's an HTML 5
template called canvas this I'm sure a
lot of you who do any kind of web dev
have probably heard of it cuz it seems
pretty popular there's like 75 different
themes basically included here I picked
one I heavily customized it and this is
the result we have a static website that
is literally just a series of HTML pages
and that is it I mean of course there's
some JavaScript as well but this is
probably as simple as you can get now
the downsides oh the downsides there's
quite quite a few downsides turns out
the biggest downside is just the sheer
amount of HTML code duplication because
HTML does not have a way to include
other HTML files which makes sense it's
just a markup language so if we take a
look over here at the old site what that
means is that we have you know like this
head section for example with a whole
bunch of stuff the header with the logo
and like a search the primary navigation
bar that's this section over here that
obviously is present on every single
page not to mention like this footer as
well like this footer this copyright
everything everything that you see over
here in the bottom that's going to be
present on every single page because as
the pages changed we just change the
content in the middle that's how a lot
of websites work so then how do I get
that to happen well I have to go into
every page and make sure that I have the
exact same code if you can even call it
code the exact same content and if one
of these changes I have to go through
every page and update it manually now
yes this sounds horrific but when there
are only like four or five pages and
it's a static website that isn't
constantly being updated it's not like
the worst thing in the world but clearly
it it kind of sucks right now this kind
of limitation on HTML uh is obviously
common uh everyone knows about this
which is why people generally create
engines or applications that generate
HTML in fact that's what basically every
single way to develop websites really is
because of course at the end of the day
the content that's being served to your
browser is going to be in HTML you don't
really stumble up a website and oh
that's not written in HTML it's written
in another language it almost always
ends up being HTML at the end of the day
and so then when you're deciding how to
make a website it usually comes down to
how do I want to generate that HTML and
that could be anything from you know PHP
or node.js which at the end of the day
will spit out HTML or something much
more simple than that a static site
generator now static site generators are
fantastic I discovered these probably
around a year or two ago and what these
tend to do is they tend to generate HTML
based on some form of input at its core
the most simple case that I see for
static side generators is basically hey
I would like to include HTML files in
other HTML files so how about this I
write an HTML file called like header or
footer. HTML and then I'm going to put
you know all of this code that belongs
to the footer inside that footer. HTML
file and then maybe I can just somehow
include my footer HTML here and of
course this isn't valid HTML but the
static side generator is an application
that will pause this and it will just
copy and paste the contents in like an
include in C++ or something like that
that's already miles better because now
elements that are common I can just
store centrally and just have them be
included so that for me was a starting
point I honestly just wanted a way to do
this because that still keeps everything
really super clean and flexible it's
just HTML at the end of the day can edit
HTML directly and the thing about these
static side generators is they're not
constantly running it's not like when
you open say a WordPress website or a
node.js website the server has to run
and execute something and then serve
your browser with that generated HTML
basically every single time I mean of
course there's going to be some caching
going on but aside from that it's still
hey server I'm requesting something I
need you to now do something no these
static sites they don't get generated
every time you browse to them you build
them it's it's kind of like compiling a
program you just build them from this
Source material that you've created and
then it generates a bunch of HTML files
into a directory which you then serve
that that directory that it generates
into that's your directory that you
serve as your website so all you're
doing is pre- generating a bunch of HTML
files and then that's your website which
just means that anytime you do want to
update say this footer or this HTML in
that Source directory you just rerun the
static site generator to regenerate the
page or the entire website and you're
done so I did a bunch of research on
static side generators I tried some of
them out and the one that I just loved
honestly was Hugo Hugo is 100% free it's
open source it's super simple and super
fast but yet it's quite deep and it's
quite complex and you can do quite a lot
with it now the thing that really sold
me I think towards Hugo was well their
documentation first of all was really
really nice and clean and
straightforward but also they have a lot
of themes they have a bunch of themes
you can see how many they have for each
category there's a lot of themes here
and to me that was really important
because first of all it speaks to the
popularity of this framework if there's
a lot of themes that means probably a
lot of people use it but then also we
come back to the how easy is this to set
up and if there's a lot of themes to
choose from then I'm probably not going
to have a problem finding something that
I like for Hazel and I'm not going to
have to spend too much time designing
something myself so there's plenty of
really nice looking themes here but for
the Hazel engine website I ended up
picking this one here called tail Bliss
there's a live demo which is really nice
you'll notice it looks quite similar to
the Hazel website because I am using
this theme of course I ended up
customizing the colors and a lot of the
other parts of the site as well which
was really easy to do and by the way
there's also a light theme for those of
you who prefer that now what I'm going
to do is I'm going to show you how you
can set something like this up yourself
and for that we're going to be using
hostinger the sponsor of this video
because they have a fantastic Black
Friday sale on at the moment okay so all
you have to do is go to hosting.com
Cherno if we scroll down over here you
can see they have a bunch of VPS hosting
plans you can pick anything you like
honestly for just a static website the
first tier will be good at enough and
you can always scale up really easily if
you need to now specifically for what
we're doing here there are a couple of
important things that hostinger has here
first of all full route access that's
obviously very important because we want
to be able to fully control our server
they use nvme discs which of course
perform really well and that's going to
help us quickly generate these websites
as well as their AMD epic CPUs that they
use are also really fast so if we just
go ahead and add this to cart it's
really important that you click this
have a coupon code and you type in Cho
because that's going to give you an even
bigger discount you can see that's gone
down from $79 to $71 now once you have
purchased a in a VPS it's super easy to
set up it probably take you less than 10
minutes all you have to do is pick your
operating system set your root password
pick your region and then here we are in
the dashboard so I'm going to grab this
IP address and then what I'm going to do
is I'm going to add a new SSH host so
I'm using remote SSH I talked about this
in a previous video but basically it's
an extension for visual studio code
which I highly highly highly recommend
if you're going to be doing any kind of
remote server work like this because it
basically just makes it feel like you're
just doing it locally so over here I'm
going to add a new SSH host I'm going to
type in SSH root at that IP address and
I'm going to put it into my config then
I'm going to hit F1 connect to host I'm
going to connect to that host I'm going
to type in my root password which I hope
I remember and then we can just go ahead
and open a folder let's go ahead and put
this into like VAR www I'll open this
for now I'm going to go ahead and create
a new folder here though called Hugo and
then inside Hugo I'm just going to open
in integrated terminal so now I have a
terminal ready to go so if we go to the
documentation here there's a getting
started guide and a quick start let's
first of all install Hugo on Linux the
way I did this is I just used the
pre-built binaries on the latest release
page so there's a bunch over here now
there are two additions there's just a
normal Hugo and there's a Hugo extended
I recommend the extended one because it
just has more features and if you want
to use the tail Bliss theme for example
you have to use the extended one because
tail Bliss will not work with just
regular Hugo so that's an important
thing to know so we're going to go ahead
and grab this Hugo extended version
we're going to grab the
amd64 Deb pack package over here so
we'll copy this copy the link address
and then I'm just going to use W get
over here to just acquire this it's
going to go ahead and download and
you'll see it over here in your Explorer
as well now all I have to do to install
it is just run D package like that-i and
then that file basically and that's
going to go ahead and install Hugo and
if I just run Hugo you can see it works
right so I can type in Hugo version for
example and it will tell me that I have
this version installed which is great so
now back to the documentation on the
quick start page if we take a look at
this we just need to create a new site
over here and then grab some kind of
theme for this so if I just type in Hugo
new site and I'll call it example it's
going to go ahead and create this
example folder with a lot of this
content so you can see we've got
example.org my new Hugo site that kind
of stuff here and then probably the
easiest way to add a theme is just to
initialize this as a git repository and
just add the theme as a git subm module
into the themes directory so if we go
back to the themes that Hugo has I'm
going to grab this one here called paper
cuz it's really simple you can see see a
demo of it over here by the way it's got
a light and a dark theme as well which
is nice so if we go ahead and click on
download I'm going to grab the URL I'll
go into the example directory over here
and do get in it and then I'll just do
get subm module add I'll paste in that
URL and I'll add it to themes SLP paper
so that's it I have a theme it's called
paper you can see the contents over here
which is great if I go back to this
hugo. toml file which has this like
really basic config here I can just set
the theme here to be paper now typically
themes come with like example content so
you can see this example side has
content layout static all of this stuff
so if you grab this content for example
and you paste it into the root directory
this original content folder is just
empty so I can just go ahead and delete
that and I'll rename this content that
we just pasted in to just be content if
I now just run Hugo to build this you
can see it's going to build like 39
pages that were inside that content
directory and that's going to go into
this public directory so you can see now
that we have like an index HTML and all
of this stuff has actually been
generated so now it's just a matter of
pointing your web server at that public
directory so over here inside this
Apache file I'm just going to set that
to be Hugo and then public or I could
just also copy the path to just make
sure that my document route is set up
correctly there it is Hugo example
public now the Hazel website actually
uses engine X instead of Apache but it's
definitely trivial to set it up either
way and then if we navigate to this URL
you can see our absolutely beautiful
website over here now the CSS you can
see it looks like it's trying to fetch
it from example.org so back over here
inside our config file let's just make
sure that this is in fact set to the
correct URL and if we just run Hugo
again hit refresh there you go so you
can see we now have our beautiful Hugo
site now all of these articles or pages
that we have here if we want to add a
new one we can just type in Hugo new
content and then if we take a look at
the content you can see there's like
this post directory for example so we
could just type in like post SL hall.md
that's going to go ahead and create it
here it is hello. MD it's created it
with today's date as well draft is set
to true so I'll have to set that to
false if I want to see it on the website
otherwise it'll only appear in draft
builds and then I can just say something
like hello this is an example and then
if I go ahead and build this I'll
refresh the page and then there it is
hello so this is my beautiful page this
is a featured article that's why it's
like pinned up the top but that's just
something this theme allows you to do
and again I want to stress that if you
do want to change any of this is just
super easy too like if we go back to the
theme and then into layouts we've got
partials we've got default inside
default we have list which is what
you're seeing over there and then you
can see here are our articles and how
they're being displayed if we scroll
down a little bit you'll see this
featured article over here and
specifically you can see here that
there's an if greater than weight zero
so articles have like some kind of
weight to them and you can see this
placeholder text one has a weight of 10
so if I was to change that for example
and rebuild it you can see it's no
longer a featured article so it's really
easy to just go in here and change
whatever really you need to change the
single HTML is what you see when you
actually look at like a single page so
if we open up this for example this view
here with like the way you have like
previous and next article that's all
inside single so here's for example the
next and previous page and it's just
HTML that you can go ahead and customize
the pho for example it's over here if
you want to change something or add
something maybe I want to stick
something in to the footer of like every
page or something like that I can just
Chuck that in there and then you can see
that there's my little hello text over
here in the footer so easy easy simple
wonderful works really well I love this
workflow inside Visual Studio code with
like the terminal I don't know I think
this is my favorite way at the moment to
make any kind of static website if I
just need to get some information out
onto the web in a simple easy but yet
extendable and powerful enough way where
I'm not repeating myself and I'm still
keeping the actual data the actual
content clean in markdown files in this
case I think Hugo is just amazing I'll
have a link obviously in the description
below to Hugo to the new Hazel website
to the tail Bliss theme to The Paper
theme and of course also to hosting.com
Cho they're having an amazing Black
Friday sale up until the 3rd of December
so go ahead and grab yourself a VPS if
you need one before it's too late and I
will see you guys next time goodbye